Одну з цих овець мені доведеться сьогодні забити.
Худоба належить фермеру Венделіну Шмюкеру. Його родина у цьому бізнесі з 1750!
Вівці Шмюкера більшу частину року проводять на пасовиську. Знайти придатні для випасу землі вівчарю доволі важко.
Як правило, вівці потребують один гектар площі. Один гектар - щодня!
Вони з'їдають один гектар щодня?
Так, 10 тисяч квадратних метрів - на 700 овець.
Це означає, що такого поля вистачить отарі лише на один день. Коли траву з'їдено, отара повертається у стайню.
Одну з цих тварин я, схоже, маю вбити.
Сподіваюсь, що ягня, яке я забиватиму, буде більшого розміру.
Воно справді більше. Ягняті 6 місяців, і воно важить близько 40 кілограмів. Я не уявляв, як швидко вони ростуть.
Я справді не знаю, чи зможу.
Поступово звикаю до думки, що вбивство - складова виробництва м'яса. Спершу я маю перевезти ягня на бійню.
Так, 40 кілограмів - це відчутно.
До бійні їхати 10 хвилин. Це ніщо у порівнянні з багатоденними переїздами, які доводиться терпіти іншій худобі.
Марко Кер - м'ясник, протягом усього процесу він буде мені допомагати.
Вже більше десяти років він працює у цій сфері.
Марко забиває лише тих тварин, яких йому приводять люди для власного споживання.
Що ти відчував, коли ти вперше забив тварину?
Так, перший раз не забувається. І мене теж перший раз знудило. Це був для мене перебір. Не через кров. Просто в цю мить вмирає тварина.
І ти усвідомлюєш це, коли це вже сталося. І вже не можна нічого вдіяти.
Ти теж це усвідомиш, лише коли це станеться. Але ми якось впораємося з цим.
Марко показує мені, як поводитися з пістолетом для забиття худоби.
Цей гвинт руйнує мозок вівці. Після цього вона нічого не відчуватиме.
Легко тримаєш у руці та натискаєш. Сміливіше!
Це був постріл.
Наче справжня рушниця!
А тепер голова ягняти під розстріл.
Найвища точка. Лінія з'єднання. Там. Пальці геть. Прибери палець. Заряджаєш і натискаєш.
Ніж. Проколюєш. Правильно проколюй! Тепер ще раз.
Це ж ціла купа крові.
Усе. Тепер він це зробив.
Ну, і як тобі?
Все відбулося так швидко. Я гадаю, спочатку потрібно це перетравити.
Я вбив тварину.
Але це був лише перший крок.
Суперпостріл, справді!
Від стейка або ковбаси ми ще далеко. Спочатку треба відсікти голову. Тоді ноги і шкіру тварини. Це легше, ніж я думав.
Це не масове виробництво? Не завжди можна отримати таке ягня?
Це так, це так. Але в цьому якраз і особливість. І елемент екологічності.
Люди тоді інакше до цього ставляться. Особливо у випадку з такою твариною.
Ще треба позбутися нутрощів.
Рівно на одну ніч у холодильник.
Одну ніч все це мусить полежати. Тоді буде легше переробляти.
Я гадаю, те, що сталося на бійні, мені запам'ятається назавжди. Цей вистріл, звуки, запахи.
Однак лише таким чином можливе екологічне споживання м'яса.
З тими обсягами м'яса, які ми сьогодні їмо, це абсолютно неможливо.
І все одно для мене це... Я не знаю, чи зможу колись знову піти до супермаркету й сказати... Так, це м'ясо я хочу з'їсти.
Наступного ранку. Настав час вирізати стейки, заради яких ми так старалися. Однак розпотрошити ягня - теж непросто.
Близько 20 кілограмів ягняти в процесі втрачаються. Це здебільшого хутро та нутрощі.
О, виглядає справді круто!
Саме так. Тоді для початку ковбаски? - Так. - Тоді сюди.
Не буду брехати... це справді, справді дуже смачно! Тому я не почуваюся винним.
Це ягня мало добре життя і померло доброю смертю.
І я не стану вегетаріанцем. Однак м'ясо - справді лише для особливих приводів.
Коли забиваєш худобу, як 100-150 років тому, тоді треба і їсти м'ясо так,
як 100-150 років тому. Це означає: лише один стейк на тиждень - і годі.